>> Tucker: THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS TRYING TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF YOU WHO
EXACTLY THE RUSSIA HOAX, THE
COLLUSION HOAX TOOK OFF AND
WHAT ROLE OUR INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES PLAYED IN PROMOTING
IT.
THAT INVESTIGATION IS
UNDERWAY NOW IT'S TERRIFYING
TO MANY IN WASHINGTON.
INTEL COMMUNITIES AREN'T
USED TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS
FROM ANYONE.
THEY DON'T LIKE IT.
THE NATIONAL MEDIA EXIST TO
SERVE THE POWERFUL AND IN
PARTICULAR PROTECT THE INTEL
AGENCIES AND THEY, OF
COURSE, RUSH TO THEIR
DEFENSE.
NTSB FOR EXAMPLE GIVES
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR JOHN
BRENNAN VIRTUALLY UNLIMITED
AIR TIME TO SPEW PROPAGANDA.
HIS LATEST A CONSPIRACY
THEORY ABOUT HOW THE
PRESIDENT CAN, QUOTE, TURN
OFF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
CIA.
>> I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE UPCOMING PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
IT'S VERY CONCERNED HELP
MR. TRUMP IN 2016.
IS MR. TRUMP TURNING A BLIND
EYE TO THAT BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T MIND IF THE RUSSIANS
INVOLVE THEMSELVES AGAIN TO
TRY TO ENHANCE HIS PROSPECTS
FOR RE-ELECTION?
IT'S REALLY QUITE UNNERVING
TO THINK THAT THIS
PRESIDENT, MR. TRUMP, CAN,
IN FACT, TURN OFF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND INTELLIGENCE
CAPABILITIES IF THEY POSE A
THREAT TO HIM PERSONALLY.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S A RIDICULOUS THING TO
ALLEGE.
OF COURSE GOT NO PUSH BACK
WHATSOEVER FROM THE MSNBC
ANCHOR SETTING ON THE SET AT
THE TIME.
MEANWHILE ON THE OTHER
PROPAGANDA REPORTER SAID TO
VIEWERS WITH A COMPLETELY
STRAIGHT FACE THAT ANY
OVERSIGHT OF THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES IS,
QUOTE:  TROUBLING.
WATCH.
>> YOU KNOW THIS REPORT IN
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" ANY
MENTION THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOW
QUESTIONING CIA OFFICERS AS
THEY REVIEW THIS RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
WHICH IS TROUBLING BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT -- YOU
DON'T DO.
THIS THE CIA KIND OF
OPERATES IN THEIR OWN WORLD.
>> Tucker: YEAH, YOU JUST
DON'T DO IT.
THEY OPERATE ON THEIR OWN.
THEY ARE NOT IN THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND.
NO LONGER A DEMOCRACY.
TROUBLING WHEN YOU ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE CIA.